there was a guy who was a headliner
right
and he said well i was doing a show
somewhere
i don't even know where maybe like
rochester or something or texas
and he said after the show some hot girl
came like beeline for me after the show
because you know like at funny moments
if you do the show then you kind of go
to the bar
yeah you know and so you migrate
especially when like you're just coming
up it's like where you go to like
show your feathers sell some mercy if
there's any ladies
and you're at the bar and you're
pretending that you're like not noticing
who's coming over but you know
oh you're heavily noticing yeah and if
nobody comes over it hurts
a lot so anyway this guy says i'm at
this i'm at this this lady comes over
and she's like b-lining for me and she's
like really hot she's
really coming on to me and immediately
she said let's go back to your hotel oh
she says let's go back to my place
and the guy's like man you know he's
thinking i gotta leave in the morning or
whatever
you know let's go back to my hotel it's
close so they go back to his hotel
and they're kind of kissing and making
out a little bit and like she's like all
over them and she's acting kind of crazy
and she keeps saying let's go
to my place let's go to my place have
some drugs at my place
so finally uh it gets too much
like the ladies just being like way too
crazy and the guy just kicks her out
says look you gotta you gotta leave you
know like this is just
i don't know what's going on you gotta
leave so when she's leaving out of the
hotel
she sees the feature that was working
there right i guess he's coming in you
know doing whatever he's been doing
eating hot dogs
so she runs into him she says hey
that guy just kicked me out do you want
to come back to my place and the feature
is like
yeah yeah you know this is better than
the four hot dogs i just ate right
so anyway next thing you know they're in
a taxi they get dropped off it's like
about a 15
20 minute drive it's kind of like out
into the burbs you know out into the
woods
they go into the house um
they lay they like she like takes him
into this room kind of takes his clothes
off and stuff
um and they do some pills they do some
type of a drug right
and then she like handcuffs him to the
bed and starts giving him a [ __ ]
well uh she passes out
in the middle of the blow [ __ ]
so he doesn't know what to do he's
handcuffed to the bed right he's like
what am i even gonna do this before cell
phone so he's like holy [ __ ] i don't
know what to do like i can't even call
9-1-1
some headlights come across the house
like somebody pulling into the driveway
i don't know so he hears the front door
open
a man comes an older man comes
looks in the room sees him there
comes in picks the girl up takes her out
of there
then goes into the kitchen like makes
himself something to eat right
the whole time this dude's freaking the
[ __ ] out right losing his mind
he then the guy comes back into the room
and says this is what he's this is what
he said he goes
um that's my daughter right oh no
no no and uh
and i never want you to come over here
again right
then give the dude a [ __ ] bro
the guy did the dad give the dude a
[ __ ] right there
on his penis bro and then then there's
the crazy part
uh took him drove him to a pay phone and
dropped him off and the
dude called the headliner said hey man i
need you to get in a taxi or something
and come get me i need some help
and so he got in a taxi to go get him
and that's where he was
i mean that's the story he told him when
he got in let me tell you something
first of all
i mean that dude takes his job as a
parent a little too seriously
you don't get to pick up where she
though you know what i mean it's not an
iou like you know
this is where you use a spanking i mean
you don't have to pick up the [ __ ]
for your daughter bro was he like
what were you doing blow job all right
like it seems like you know what i mean
that's probably didn't need to
that's the gnarly story i've ever heard
yeah but let me
and my second question is man i
why is this dude getting hard for for
dad like that seems like
it could have been out of fear fear hard
a fear heart a fear boner
i think can you get erections out of
fear we look that up please sean i'm
sure
some people love that do you know that
there's a whole
uh porn site where people
like to masturbate but they use tears as
lubricants oh my god
that is like the to me that's a
different
let's like it's recycling but it's too
much yeah it is
i like it it's environmentally i like it
but like here we go an individual has a
condition is a
phallophobe the term is derived from the
word phallo in greek meaning penis and
at times denoting masculinity
dude coupled with the suffix phobia so
you said penis
there was a guy who played baseball
against us when i was growing up his
last name was p-e-n-n-i-s
oh wow penis but not in high school your
name wasn't penis
no hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one